you
[Music]
New York Times bestselling author Linda
Fair Stein is considered one of today's
finest crime fiction writers for 30
years she prosecuted sex crime cases in
New York City they included the
so-called preppy killer Robert Chambers
Farah Stein was also one of the first
prosecutors in the country to introduce
DNA evidence in courts as a crime writer
her Alexandra Cooper series has been
translated to more than a dozen
languages her latest work is deadfall
it's a 19th novel in the series author
and fame crime writer Lee Child calls
her I like this title the queen of
intelligence suspense you go Linda
Fairchild knows what he's talking about
so before we get started I'm wondering
are you feeling all tingly because
you're sitting here with Charlie Rose
back in 1993
Charlie her first interview was with yes
my first book was nonfiction sexual
violence
9 times later and 19 books later but to
be you know the credibility gave to have
you sitting there authenticating in that
dark set that said you did a good job
[Laughter]
but here we are with deadfall I think
what's so fascinating is that it said in
New York at the Met Ball of all places
and I'm wondering was it difficult to
start this book because it's it picks up
an hour later after your last book
easiest book I ever started fellows last
year's killer look ends with a murder
and so this one I knew an hour later
that Alice would be in the morgue with
the victim whom she knew and she was
shooting it was her boss and he actually
fell into her arms when he was killed so
she's got bloodstains and we turned the
table I turned the tables on her and she
without thinking becomes a suspect in
the new the new book right away she's a
prosecutor everybody always thinks that
Alexandra Cooper in some form another
must be you because when I was reading
the book there were many things like the
way you question a witness the way
somebody answers a question you had
little things sprinkled throughout that
I thought I wonder if that happened to
her in real life like if somebody says
they're drinking Linda what does that
really mean well many people when
they've been the victim of a crime
want to minimize they want you to think
better of them in law enforcement so
they'll often say I had a drink I had a
drink and a half and you talked to the
bartender says she knocked down four
drinks or three eat the question after
you asked oh if I repeat the question if
I repeat the question after I'm trying
to think of an answer don't be the best
answer so I turned those again around on
her how exchanged so nine put nineteen
books later I'm actually 24 year old 24
years older than when I first created
her she's aged 3 years which is pretty
nice
so physically it's been a 35 she's only
38 but she's learned from the
experiences it's not easy to work with
victims of violent violent crime and
especially in sexual assault domestic
violence areas so you see that change in
her throughout several books ago she was
kidnapped obviously got out of it fine
but she's had some PTSD that she's dealt
with and this event sort of brings her
in Deadpool back to me it's not easy to
to war to work with it it also can't be
easy to write about it a lot of times I
think that's a good question definite I
didn't view it originally as being
cathartic but it is and it was such a
dark world when Charlie first talked to
me you know people really thought what
do you do why do you do this work it
can't be rewarding it's just dark and
for me it was richly rewarding because
we were getting for the first time
justice in court for victims of this
kind of intimate violence so to write
about it I mean I think helped me work
through a lot of the issues and then
give it to the reader how do you get
better at what you do do you read other
very good crime writers and if so who
are they yes I read em all the time
Harlan Coben is a good friend of the
show and Lee Child and Mary Higgins
Clark and Lisa scottoline II David
Baldacci probably changed my writing
style without knowing it how did he do
that I'd written three books my late
husband and I had lunch with him and in
prep for the lunch my husband raced
through a bunch of his books and he said
David you and every chapter with the
tea's you make me want a page turn at
the end of every chapter I can't go to
sleep that kind of
writers dream I said maybe maybe it's
something I ought to do so I credit
David Baldacci style for getting me to
to not end with a funny word exactly
what you did in this book I know the
question yeah she ends with something
that you want to know what's gonna
happen so even if you want to stop you
go well now I got to figure now I got to
keep going cuz I want to know what's
gonna happen they called you hell on
heels why well that was a I think a
compliment at the time I didn't much
think so but the Daily News did it was
not what my colleagues did but once that
headline ran stuff there was a lot of
teasing and that was fun but there's a
30-year career long career so why does
that mean because you're tough because
what tough was important to be I didn't
go there as a kid at a law school
thinking I would ever be tough thinking
this would be a prosecutorial career
fair was the most important thing so
that combination the heels were good at
the time as you know I love the Sunday
morning peace on you where you said it
dreamed to have a career I wanted all my
life because writing who would think
that this would turn out so that's what
I wanted my dad used to say get a grip
you know you need a career get a job you
can't sit in a garret writing books all
day and this great career in the law
gave me deadfall gave me books thank you
to you all thank you good Thank You
Linda fair Stein